Scientists are driven to answer questions that,
you know, they're confronted with in their everyday world. And the
biologists in the 1800s were confronted with the fact that there were many
different species on the face of the earth, and there were many differences between
individuals,
even within a species.
And so it was very natural,
I think,
to ask the question,
why aren't we all identical?
Why don't all humans look exactly alike?
Why don't humans look exactly like an ape?
What drives the differences?
That's the whole concept of inheritance, that somehow when a human has a kid,
it looks like a human and doesn't look like an ape.
On the other hand,
the question is,
well,
once you accept that there is a system of inheritance which will allow things to be perpetuated,
then how'd you ever get anything that was different from each other?
So if apes we think are the precursor to humans,
if you have a system which perpetuates apes, then how do you ever get a human out of an ape?
And so I think around them,
what the biologists were drawing was this paradox of there are clearly these ways for
inheritance to work where it can perpetuate a species
by having individuals,
the progeny, look like the parents,
but there also had to be some way to change that inheritance to give rise to a new
species.
One idea is that there's some kind of genetic material that is transmitted from one organism to
another,
which specifies that the progeny be exactly like their parents.
Once you acknowledge that there's genetic material and that genetic
change has to happen,
change to that genetic material, has to happen in order to generate new traits,
new species. There were two big models that tried to explain that.
One of the models was championed by a scientist named Lamarck, who postulated
that the change was in the genetic material that occurred,
it was a consequence of the response to the environment,
that is,
the environment somehow caused the genetic material to acquire a
difference, a mutation you might call it, altered it's state such that it could now convey a new
trait.
I mean,
the example would be here, is that giraffes might have had short necks,
initially,
they could chew the leaves of the trees.
And then what happened was the trees grew taller,
so the giraffes,
in order to reach the leaves on trees,
stretch their necks,
and the process of stretching their necks caused them to change
the genetic material within them,
that gave rise then to baby giraffes,
which had longer necks.
And so this was called the induced mutation model.
The other model was championed by descendants of Darwin,
and the basic idea there was that changes in genetic material
happened all the time,
they happened spontaneously.
And so in any population of giraffes,
most of them will be an average height of,
let's say,
whatever it is, 12 feet,
but there'll be an occasional giraffe which was 14 feet tall.
And when the trees grow taller,
the giraffe who happens to be 14 feet tall can reach those tall leaves,
but the other giraffes that are 12 feet tall, can't. They die off.
The giraffe that's 14 has babies and all its progeny does well,
and so now all of a sudden, all the giraffes are generally an average of 14 feet tall, instead of being 12 feet tall.
And so this was called spontaneous mutation model.
So those were the two models at the time. The controversy persisted for 50
years because there were three main hurdles that really confronted solving or addressing
which of the models was correct.